left i want to make sure i get this
right the most dominating playoff
performance in defeat it can be super
bowl it can be a playoff run it can be a
playoff game so it gives us a lot of
different ways we can go and sometimes
it's harder when there's a lot of
different ways right chris you get the
call i know what the first pick is going
to be we've kind of given it away so the
first pick is for who gets larry
fitzgerald chris
go ahead it is rigged go ahead take
tails please
go ahead i'll let you have valerie
fitzgerald why would you not pick heads
after what happened for the patriots on
sunday see
heads never sheds
that's the only word i can think of that
rhymes with heads
go ahead take them i'll take larry
fitzgerald in 2008 the entire playoff
run beginning to end he elevated his
game to a higher level it was incredible
and uh he should have gotten a super
bowl win out of it that that was when we
first started thinking of the guy as a
hall of famer it was only his fifth nfl
season so yes larry fitzgerald and end
of story hand off the checker final
answer i win oh my gosh you're so
ridiculous you're you're unbelievable
okay i mean hey that was a great
performance it wasn't even the best
performance i've seen at a wide receiver
in a losing effort i'm going to give
that one to terrell owens and what he
did coming off a broken leg against the
new england patriots i mean the fact
that he broke his ankle what was it
stats nine weeks before eight weeks
before uh and was able to play and be
the number one wide receiver on the
field i know dion branch had a good day
that day as well on the other side but
be the number one threat for the
philadelphia eagles and what they did
and for him to play you know in a game
of course of that magnitude and him have
to
uh you know rush his recovery to make it
and then you know just deliver a lot
more than i certainly expected at the
time i thought he was going to just be a
shell of himself a guy that was going to
be used as a decoy but was really the
focal point of the eagles game plan nine
catches 122 yards you know on a short
time after a broken leg where we didn't
think he's going to play i got to give
him a lot of credit for that performance
the guts the toughness everything about
it
yeah and and right owens had that one
game in the postseason and he would have
been the mvp if the eagles had won the
game just like fitzgerald would have
been the mvp
of super bowl 43 if the cardinals had
won the game i i am
this is where the first two were easy
now it gets a little difficult stop
writing things in there staff he's not
i'm not looking at what he's writing
okay but brady tom brady last year in
super bowl 52 that was my next pick i
had it down to him and another guy i
went with brady because the other guy i
don't think you're going to take tom
brady had 505 passing yards last year
three touchdowns and no picks in a
defeat to the philadelphia eagles in
large part because malcolm butler was on
the sideline the entire game but i'm
sure no one is bitter about that a year
later i wonder if there's any fumes of
that floating around as the patriots get
ready for super bowl 53 regardless brady
had a performance better than most
quarterbacks having winning efforts
brady was dominant we're not going to
think of him because oh he's already got
his five rings he should have six you
could argue he should have seven you
could argue he's done everything in his
power to have eight yeah chris no
definitely i mean certainly has uh
stats stop writing this crap and he was
not gonna i already had that
i'll send you a screenshot yeah tom
brady last year i had to 2004 tom brady
last year okay so take that all right
i'm gonna go one that's a little maybe
less popular okay a little a one that i
don't think anybody's thinking of but
this is one of the all times that means
it's going to be really good all-time
great defensive performances by a guy
that is by no means a household name and
how about super bowl 50 coney ealy okay
they lost the football game but coney
ealy had three sacks and an interception
and a pass defended in the football game
i mean that's that's a pretty remarkable
stat line for a defense i mean von
miller won mvp with two and a half sacks
in that game and here was coney ealy
with an interception and three sacks
added on to that uh i thought that was a
pretty incredible effort by him on that
day where man that was a that was a
great super bowl uh
you know i you know that was a nail
biter that was awesome to watch but
coney eely yeah he deserves a little
credit for what he did on that day that
was a special moment for him and his
biggest game of his life
and and i remember thinking that if
coney ely had been a free agent going
into that offseason how much money he
would have made but he still was under
contract for one more year right he
eventually didn't get traded to the
patriots and then the patriots cut him
yeah was it something like that there
was something like that i feel like
there was a team somewhere in between
but i i didn't like the jets he played
for the jets he's played for the raiders
but it felt like this guy was on the
brink of becoming a star but but just
like other super bowl heroes who who won
the game and won the mvp and went on to
do nothing dexter jackson remember him
with your tampa bay buccaneers although
that was the year before you got there
right uh uh uh oh the guy the guy from
the college game day why am i blank
he had the great he had the great game
larry brown right the year before
desmond howard had the two picks of neil
o'donnell but those guys all won so they
don't qualify for this all right i'm
gonna go with uh a guy who had
multiple great super bowl not super bowl
performances but playoff performances in
his career never won a super bowl but
steve smith 2003
steve smith 2003
2003 the year that the panthers made it
to the super bowl and lost to the
steelers or lost to the steelers lost to
the page i'm doing two things at once
here lost to the patriots in 2002
steve smith was great in that playoff
run and this is more than just the super
bowl because the super bowl numbers
weren't great although he did have a an
impressive touchdown in the super bowl
in the post season run if i can get
these numbers to come up for two
thousand if you've already prepared it
2003. i was prepared but i looked up
coney eely in the window that i had my
steve smith information in like an idiot
135 yards against the cowboys 163 yards
against the rams in that double overtime
victory where he was shot out of a
cannon on the green cement at the edward
jones dome he only had 15 yards in the
championship game against the eagles but
then he had four catchers for 80 yards
and a 39-yard touchdown in what was a
very close wasn't it scoreless until
late in the first half of that super
bowl between the panthers and the
patriots but steve smith was impressive
and equally impressive three years later
can i pull them both together stats can
i get a career i've already filler
busted this whole segment here with like
five he was good in week 15 leading up
to the playoffs i mean holy crap are you
done if i were to if i were to display
one of these fingers to you right now
which one do you think it would be can i
show you which one i'll show you
no no no no no watch careful
oh go ahead
okay
all right i don't know i think i just
won the draft with that
long talk of steve smith and 44 catches
for 80 yards
come on let's go let's go i'm going with
thurman thomas okay super bowl 25.
thurman thomas i was there to witness it
we've talked about it a few times this
week right how belichick came up with
this great game plan to stop the k-gun
and jim kelly and they're throwing and
passing attack that was so phenomenal
they had come off a 51-3 victory uh
against the oakland or the los angeles
raiders at the time in the afc
championship game well the giants are
like we're not going to throw the ball
over the field on us and thurman thomas
had 15 rushes
15 rushes for
135 yards another five receptions for 55
yards and a few touchdowns to go along
with it he was phenomenal on that day he
was the best player on the bills team
the giants had no answer for him and
that was the first time i know in my
lifetime where i watched the super bowl
and at the end of the game i was going
man who's going to win the mvb man is
thurman thomas going to win the mvp even
if they lose this football game i mean i
know i was young but i was obsessed with
sports and i thought that might have
been one of those times but of course
o.j anderson got it because he had an
awesome day
running the rock as well
i have a harder time getting on board
with that one because the game plan was
to let thurman thomas do those things
right that was the bill belichick pitch
to the giants defensive players who
wanted to kill him when he said hey if
thurman thomas has 100 yards rushing
we're going to win this game so that fit
the whole belichick effort to take the
steam out of the k-gun offense and slow
down the buffalo bills so i don't feel
that that's the same kind of heroic
performance that terrell owens had
because i have a feeling that the the
patriots in that super bowl against the
eagles were indeed trying to take
terrell owens out of the game lawyering
this subject four receptions for 80
yards was worse than thurman thomas's
performance okay it was the whole super
bowl
what did he have in the championship
game what'd you say he had the
championship i know but he had a but
steve smith reached a new level and
2005. i want to throw i want to pull 2
000 yeah yeah you can't see it's the
career
it's the career playoff award for a guy
that never won a supervisor
just pick me as the winner now because
he's trying to change the rules of the
draft as he's on to pick three i wanted
when i got larry fitzgerald i won it
when you assumed that tails was going to
win you the coin toss larry fitzgerald
wins it wait so we got what was some
other we missed chuck hallie right who
actually did want to mvp uh in a super i
just didn't want to go back that far so
uh you know i wasn't there to witness it
you probably were um brett favre when
they lost to the denver broncos that was
another good one three touchdowns one
interception 256 yards those are other
ones that i thought about
you know you better be careful sims i'm
going to let you beat the crap out of me
in atlanta next week okay yeah you and
derek carr i don't want to hurt my hands
crap out of you i better be careful oh
trust me i'm soft it won't hurt
all right
let's recap i've got larry fitzgerald
tom brady in super bowl 52 steve smith
in 2003. you've got terrell owens 2004
coney ely super bowl 50 and thurman
thomas super bowl 25 even though bill
belichick intentionally let him shut up
[Laughter]
not making the list you mentioned chuck
hallie he's from my hometown i probably
should have taken chuck out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports